every day I'm trying not to hate myself
how does it feel to know that other
people are looking up to you for their
inspiration oh my gosh I mean role model
anything like that scares me because I'm
I'm a hot mess of a person most of the
time
um a fabulous hot mess yes you are but
hopefully uh kids will listen to my
music or things like that and and feel
in any way inspired you know that's the
dream
to love me more I know that George
Michael was someone you looked up to as
a queer artist
[Music]
there wasn't a lot of people to look up
to
um queer artists who had been through
what I've been through and and I
remember just sitting there and watching
his interviews and watching the way he
held himself he's such a huge
inspiration to me to this day Sam along
with collaborator Kim Petrus made story
with their single Unholy becoming the
first non-binary solo
solo and first trans solo artist to earn
a number one hit on the Billboard charts
[Music]
with over 1 billion streams the song is
nominated for best pop Duo slash group
performance at this year's Grammys what
means the most is just the music is the
me and Kim created something and it's a
little baby and we just never thought
people would react like this and it's so
nice to to know that the world is
dropping to yourself
I have been doing some moves that's very
good
Grammy Oscar Golden Globe winner way to
keep all those Awards oh my gosh I've
just started putting them out have you
yeah I hit them for years but why just I
don't know they're quite intense are
they yeah but now I have them out and I
and I'm proud Olivia Rodrigo well she
accidentally broke one of her Grammys no
yeah have you ever accidentally broken I
know but I can see how they're easy to
break though right yeah I feel like yeah
like this yeah but they could break like
if they fell from a high enough place
okay yeah I could see them smashing well
Julie noted so one day if they ever get
a Grammy I won't keep it up too much I
know exactly exactly exactly